okay let's go to your voicemail
voicemails can be left at two one nine
to david p here's an interesting little
question take a listen hello David
my name is Isaac I'm calling because I
wanted to know what you thought about
whether or not it's the corona virus
outbreak which is a pandemic level would
that be good for Toms reelection
prospects yeah I I don't know the answer
to that pandemic means worldwide spread
of a new disease this is certainly a new
strain of a type of disease that we are
familiar with if it if corona virus
becomes a pandemic I genuinely have no
idea whether it is or is not good for
Trump we already saw Trump
hypocritically changing his position on
corona virus to one that is very
different from what he was tweeting when
Barack Obama was dealing with Ebola back
in 2014 I don't know the answer I want
to hear from you is a corona virus
pandemic good or bad for Trump and of
course either way we want to do
everything we can to stop the spread of
corona virus I will likely have updated
numbers for you on its spread
probably on tomorrow's program let me
know what you think on the bonus show
today Harvey Weinstein has been found
guilty and immediately complained of
chest pains and was a instead of being
brought to Rikers where he was remanded
until sentencing on March 11th he was
brought to the hospital instead we will
talk about what's going on with Harvey
Weinstein we will talk about a new what
is effectively a wealth test for
immigrants that Donald Trump has put
into effect it's a rule that is a de
facto wealth test you want to come to
the United States
and lastly Ponzi schemes have hit their
highest level in a decade this is
actually an indicator aleady a possible
leading indicator about what we may
expect in the stock market in coming
years all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access by
becoming a member at join pakman.com
I'll speak to you then and hope to see
you tonight on the live stream for the
South Carolina Democratic presidential
debate twitch
YouTube and Facebook live starting about
45 minutes before the debate I'll see
you then